it's the first rule the audience learns
in John Wick and it's the one that gets
Jon in the most trouble you know the
rules no business can be conducted on
these premises lest incurring heavy
penalties guests are required to leave
all grudges and contracts at the door
that way they can enjoy a drink and a
good night's sleep without worrying
about whether they'll wake up JN breaks
this cardinal rule when he kills Santino
dantonio in the New York Continental Bar
at the end of chapter too this leads to
not only his own excommunication but
consequences for anyone who aided the
assassination or his escape from the
high tables judgment Winston nearly
loses his position and his life for
offering Jon a 1-hour head start from
Pursuit the Continental is sacred not
just as a base but as a symbol that
allows these coldblooded killers to see
themselves as civilized